이 챕터에서는
양자 컴퓨터와 고전 컴퓨터가
어떻게 협력해서 가장 중요한 과제 중 하나를 해결하는지 살펴볼 거야
과학에서 분자와 물질의 에너지를 정확히 추정하는 건데 이걸
quantum circuit을 써서 달성할 수 있어
quantum circuit을 이용해서
기저 예시들을 생성한 다음
그걸 후처리하고
더 큰 행렬을 대각화하는 거야
이 루틴 계열에는
SQV나 SKG 같은 것들이 있고 IBM 양자 플랫폼에
이것들만을 위한 강좌가 따로 있어
이 방법들과 관련된 다른 방법들도 마찬가지고
우리 목적에 맞게 이 강의에서는
설명을 간단히 할 거야
SQV를 쓰든 SKG를 쓰든 상관없이
목표는 해밀토니안 행렬의 고유벡터를 찾는 거야
그리고 고유값도 찾아야 해
이 행렬은 물리적인 계의 에너지를 나타낼 수도 있고
화학 계를 나타낼 수도 있지만 같은 프레임워크로
다른 많은 문제 유형들도 다룰 수 있어
물류 같은 것도 포함해서
이런 행렬들이 엄청나게 클 때가 있어
그래서 행렬의 차원을 줄이면서
중요한 특성들을 보존하는 게
바닥 상태와 관련해서
엄청난 가치를 가질 수 있어 그게 SQV의 목표야
양자 컴퓨터를 이용해서 유용한 부분공간을 생성하는 거야
바닥 상태를 포함하는 부분공간을
그러면 해밀토니안 행렬을 그 부분공간에 투영할 수 있고
그 결과 작은 행렬이 남는데
그게 훨씬 더 쉽게
대각화 분석을 할 수 있어
고전적인 고성능 컴퓨팅으로 이걸 하는 방법은
시험용 양자 상태를 준비하는 거야
흔히 앤사츠라고 불리는 걸 써서
측정을 수행해서 그 앤사츠를 샘플링하고
계산 기저에서 측정하는 거야 그러면
계산 기저에서 샘플된 부분공간을 얻게 돼
하지만 우리가 정말 찾고 싶은 건
진짜 바닥 상태야 만약에
샘플된 부분공간이 포함하지 않는다면
필요한 성분들을 다 갖고 있지 않다면
더 좋은 앤사츠를 선택하면
바닥 상태를 더 잘 추정할 수 있을 거야
그게 샘플 기반으로 이어지는 거야
크리얼 양자 대각화, 즉 SKUDY야 SKUDY에서는
전처럼 앤사츠로 시작하지만
그다음에 물리 계의 시간 진화를 근사하는 quantum gate들을 적용해
물리 계의 시간 진화를 근사하는 거야
몇 가지 가정 하에
이게 시간 진화된 앤사츠와 진짜 바닥 상태 사이의 겹침에 대한 보장을 제공해
앤사츠와 진짜 바닥 상태 사이의
이 두 알고리즘 모두 거대한 해밀토니안 행렬로 시작해
작동 방식은 좀 다르지만
두 경우 모두 알고리즘의 양자 파트가
행렬을 줄일 수 있는 부분공간을 만들어내
바닥 상태의 핵심 특성들을 보존하길 기대하면서
그러면 고성능 고전 컴퓨팅이 어디서 등장할까
가장 큰 해밀토니안들에 대해서
그리고 가장 정확한 바닥 상태 추정을 위해서는
이렇게 투영된 행렬도 꽤 클 수 있어
그래서 더 강력한 고전 컴퓨터 능력을 활용하면
더 나은 결과를 얻는 데
도움이 될 뿐만 아니라
더 큰 문제들을 다룰 수 있게도 해줘
이걸 다 합쳐보면
샘플 기반 알고리즘들을
다양한 프로그래밍 모델들의 조합으로 표현할 수 있어
이종 리소스 세트에서
예를 들어 알고리즘을
태스크 워크플로우로 표현할 수 있는데 거기에 태스크가 있어
타겟 상태와 겹치는 quantum circuit 준비를 위한 태스크와
타겟 상태에 대한 태스크가 이어져
transpiler 작업을 위한 태스크인데 이건 고전적인 리소스만 필요해
다음으로 실행될 태스크는
primitive들을 써서 quantum circuit을 실행하는 거야
이건 당연히
양자 리소스가 필요하고 그다음엔 후처리 태스크가 있어
그 자체가 병렬 대각화 알고리즘일 수도 있는데
여러 노드에서 실행되는 거야
그리고 추가로
이런 알고리즘들 중 하나를 여러 번 실행하고 싶을 수도 있어
앤사츠를 변경하면서
아니면 완전히 병렬로 실행하거나
다른 파라미터들로
이제 SKD로 모두 합쳐보자
코드로 보면 여기에 태스크 파일들이 다 있어
그리고 여기에 제출 파일들이 다 있어
매핑 태스크에서는 circuit들을 준비해
최적화 단계에서는 circuit을 최적의 방식으로 실행해
실행 태스크에서는 비트스트링을 샘플링해
준비된 상태에서
ISA circuit으로
이전 단계에서 얻은
그리고 후처리를 수행해
이제 제출할 준비가 됐어
워크플로우를 실행할 준비가
보다시피 모든 게 의존성에 따른 순서로 실행되고 있어
결과를 기다리자
그리고 출력 파일들을 확인할 수 있어
여기 최적화 단계의 출력 파일이 있어
ISA circuit이 담긴 파일이야
마지막으로 최종 결과를 확인해보자
반복 결과를
스케줄에서 확인할 수 있어
SKUDY 워크플로우 간단 시연은 여기까지야
모든 코드는 텍스트 섹션에서 볼 수 있어
또는 아래 설명란에서도 볼 수 있어
이제 몇 가지 개념과 예시들을 살펴봤어
복잡한 하이브리드 프로그램 관리를 시작하는 데 도움이 될 거야
물론 이게 표면만 긁어본 것뿐이야
이건 양자와 고전 컴퓨팅을 조합해서
할 수 있는 모든 것의 시작일 뿐이야
더 탐구하려면 Qiskit 문서와 튜토리얼을 확인해봐
IBM 양자 플랫폼에 있는
IBM 양자 플랫폼에서
텍스트 섹션의 리소스도 꼭 확인해봐
또는 설명란에서 더 많은 관련 항목들을 찾을 수 있어
시청해줘서 고마워
네